[Musique]
gerry boulet c'était l'euro car au coeur
tendre avec son groupe offenbach
il a chanté quelques unes des pièces les
plus mémorables de notre répertoire
je pense qu'on réussissait à toucher le
côté partie du monde est aussi l'homme
du monde avec surtout avec les ballades
que jerry grandey tellement bien qu'au
meilleur interprète de grand talent il
savait s'entourer d'excellents parolier
heureux mélange de sensibilité plus loin
que peut-être qu'on se reconnaît là
dessus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis
le montrer que la meilleure manière
d'être un bon un homme moderne supposé
c'était de laisser passer ses émotions
[Musique]
des chansons qui ont touché plusieurs
générations de fans qui lui voue un
amour indéfectible pour moi il y aura
même pas cent kilomètres c'est vraiment
lui qui est arrêté le rock and roll en
fait au québec
son fils justin continue de faire vivre
son héritage musical sur scène le plus
magique c'est que les gens qui sont
ramenés dans leur travail annoncera s'il
ya un temps pour moi je dit aujourd'hui
je suis
car
10 l'influencé une foule d'artistes
c'est le cas de martin deschamps grands
fans et collectionneurs de jamie gerry
boulet ses mots ma grande inspiration
gerry boulet cct comme mon professeur de
chant sans qu'il le sache et ça et puis
celui qui a animé mon adolescence par sa
musique coupe d'europe kirk sont nées de
la mouture d'offenbach en 1987 gerry
boulet apprend qu'il a le cancer
s'ensuit un long combat contre la
maladie malgré tout l'annoncé de sa mort
le 18 juillet 1990 créé une onde de choc
partout au pays
j'ai perdu mes jambes je je je me suis à
shippagan coop de manettes du gel et le
moment reste la voie unique et les
chansons d'un artiste d'exception ici
nabi alexandre chartier radio canada
montréal
monsieur buquet
messieurs du cac
[Musique]
sans merci